thanks for organizing the event
um today um the title of my talk is
recent developments in self-supervised
learning for computer vision this
actually one of the research directions
that we have at
Yann um so I'll try to cover the
motivation why it's an important problem
and then try to kind of show the history
of it got developed and then at the end
to show the recent papers that worked in
this
area so let's try to motivate the
problem and let's do it by saying that
data is expensive and if you want to
label a large data set it can be very
expensive either it will take a lot of
time or a lot of
money so for example the famous imet
data set contains around 14 million
images and then if you ask one person to
label the data set and let's say um
labeling each image takes one minute so
this will take around 22
years and then other labeling tasks such
as segmentation or pixel level
annotations they can take more time and
then even hours so if you want to have a
large data set it will take um forever
to um create a data set and then if you
do so it might be very
expensive
uh but actually
um so the traditional supervised
learning methods they uh they assume
that you have a data set and each data
point has its label so now um there's a
paradigm saying that um the images
contain enough information that um we
can take meaningful representations from
them so basically without labels if you
look at the image it contains a lot of
information and then we can try to use
this information and then find um a good
feature representation um and then try
to use this
later so this Paradigm is known as
self-supervised learning and then it's
actually a subcategory of unsupervised
learning but since recently it got um
very popular and big it got its own name
called self-supervised
learning um so first let's let's talk
about how to use it um so let's say we
have a large data set without labels and
then let's say somehow we can learn some
representations from um we can learn how
to learn representations from images and
then we can use these representations
for other tasks so we'll talk about it a
bit
later um and then the downstream task
for computer vision include
classification detection segmentation
tracking and there are many
more and then so in this figure let's
let's see um what what the idea of
self-supervised learning is is so let's
say we have a large data set we want to
learn some model some Network that if we
feed it an image it will give us a
representation of it and later we want
to use this
representation um and have a small
amount of label data set and train some
small model and then um use it
for um classification segmentation
object detection or any other Downstream
task that computer vision um includes so
the goal is to to learn this network
from unsupervised data and then use this
network for a smaller data set which is
labeled already to learn
um um to learn it for the downstream
tasks so now the question is how to
learn these
representations um we don't have any
labels so we have to come up with a plan
to learn this
representations so to do so we first
have to define a task uh which doesn't
use any labeled data but but uh we can
use the data set
itself we call this a pre-text task so
we come up with a task that doesn't need
any supervision but we can use this task
to learn some
representation um and then it's called
pre-ex because we don't really care
about this task we just want to use it
to learn
representations so let's consider a
couple of examples so um the first one
is called context
prediction so let's say we have an image
and then we take two random Patches from
it um if you ask a human to say what's
the relative position of these two
patches we can easily do so
right uh so let's try to teach this
problem um to network to right so let's
we we train a neural network which takes
input two image patches and then it
returns um a number which basically
tells us the relative position so if it
returns one it means that the relative
position is here here and then so forth
if we have two it should be on top three
on top right um so basically it's an
eight-way classification task and we
don't really care about this task but we
can use this to learn
representations um another one could
be um solving jigsaw puzzles so we can
do the same thing but a bit more um be a
a bit more complex problem so let's say
now we take nine p is from an image they
can be they should be almost adjacent to
each other and then we can ask the
network to uh we we can randomly permute
it and then ask the network to
reconstruct um the image of this uh
actually not the image but this piece of
the image that that's cut into nine
patches um again this is a harder
problem because in the previous one
there was an eight-way classification
problem but here it can um if we have
nine patches it it can be up to 9
factorial possible permutations so we
can fix n which is much smaller than 9
factorial and only allow some fixed
amount of uh permutations so in this
case the network would take an input
these nine patches and then it would
return as the
um one of the end possible
permutations again this is not a task
that we care about all we care about is
learning meaning meaningful
representations that we can later
use
um a more recent one actually
um predicts rotations so let's say we
take images and we arbitrarily rotate
them either 90° 180 Dees or
270° and then we give this image to the
network and we ask the network to
predict the rotation angle so here we
have a four-way classification problem
and then the intuition is that if um the
network understands the
content of the image it should be able
to understand whether it's rotated or
not or get the angle of rotation okay
and then so here we'll get network and
then it's a classification T task so
actually for any of this problem um all
of them
are um so the first one was 2015 the
second one 2016 this one 2018 um so most
of them used um CNN to learn um learn
the pretext task but U more recent ones
they can they can use Transformers or
your favorite
backboard again so this we don't really
care about finding the rotation but we
want to use this task to learn some
representation um but now there's an
issue with all this because the
downstream task that we have in computer
vision which are image classification
segmentation uh they have nothing to do
with with these tasks and then the
networks that we train to learn to solve
these tasks um at some point
they only care about this task so
basically we would want to have um
another way of finding features or
representations of images that are not
focused on some specific task but can
actually learn what's inside the
image
um so first first let's try to answer
the question what we would want um what
we would call a meaningful
representation so let's say um if I show
you a picture or two pictures of an
object that you've never seen you can
easily determine whether both pictures
contain the same object or not right you
don't really have to know the object to
understand whether two pictures contain
the same object or not or if one of them
is under different lighting conditions
or has a different color we can still
figure out that it's the same object we
don't really need much
information so this is what we would
expect from from these features from
this representations we want them to be
robust to some image augmentations to
rotations to um some distortions some
noise
um so why not let's try to train the
network to be um robust to these
augmentations so first let's define the
augmentations so let's say we have the
original image on top
left and then um from one of the papers
I I took I took this set of
augmentations we can crop images we can
resize them we can crop and resize
together we can drop the color we can um
add different filters we can add Goan
blur goian noise we can
cut uh piece out of the picture we can
rotate the picture and Visually if you
look at at these pictures we can easily
guess that it's the same picture and
they all contain a
dog so ideally we want to learn
representations that um if you give the
network any of these
um 10 images U it will find similar
representations so how to do
so um the naive approach would be let's
let's say we have an Network this case
called an
encoder um so we give different
augmentations to this encoder it's the
same network and then we add a loss
function making sure that um the
representations learned um or the
outputed representations are close to
each
other okay so this would be the naive
approach however this is not going to
work
because
uh it will collapse the trivial solution
um would give us a perfect loss right it
will always be zero so if you always
find the same exact um representation
for all the
images um then you would get a zero loss
so your network doesn't have to learn
any representation it can just learn
that it can just output the same exact
um representation for all the
images and then um all the recent modern
research is focused on avoiding this
issue so try try to U change one side of
this um Network or
um um somehow changing the data set
changing the the way we input the data
set um just making sure that we avoid
this um trivial
solution uh by the way this this is
called a Camus Network um we'll see it a
few few more times during this
talk okay so the first approach is
called steam
CLR um so
basically on the right you can see it's
um um architecture so it takes an image
let's say x is the image and then it
creates two different augmentations of
this image let's say x XI and
XJ and then f is the network here that
is going to give us the
representations so you apply F on both
sides to x i and XJ and then you get
this Ai and HJ so these are two
representations and then you have a
smaller Network G you apply G on both of
them you get zi and ZJ and then you try
to make sure that zi and ZJ um
agree okay so this is very similar to
what we had in previous slide but why is
this better because um so here we we can
actually Define a loss function um in a
way that helps us avoid the the collapse
that we mentioned so basically for each
batch during the training let's say for
each image we create two augmentations
and
then um two augmentations of the same
image we keep them as positive pair and
then all the other pairs are
negative and if you look at this um term
the loss function here that's written so
in the numerator it takes the expect the
exponent of the similarity between Z and
ZJ so I and J come from the same
augmentation and in the numerator so
let's say we had n images in a batch so
it sums over um all the negative pairs
so here's zi and ZK they're
augmentations of different
images so the idea
is um we want the numerator to be large
and denominator to be small which means
that the similarity between between the
same augmentations we want to be large
and then similarity between different
augmentations similarity between
augmentations of different images we
want to be
small
okay um and then on the right you can
see the sud sud code of um simr
algorithm so basically um it
takes a mini batch let's say XK K from 1
to n and then for each image it creates
two
augmentations and then it passes through
the network so it passes through the
augmentation T and then F which gives us
the representation and then G which
gives us the projection so for both
images and then um it defines it it adds
this loss function for all possible
ijs and it aims to to minimize
it so this is one approach to um to
avoid the collapse and then this was a
very successful algorithm uh it was
published icml icml
2020 uh so they did further analysis to
to see which augmentations are the most
important ones and then so if if you see
here we have crop cutout color and then
a couple of
um
um a couple of other
augmentations and then so they basically
kept
so here we needed two augmentations
to um for this experiment they kept One
Direction just to have the plain image
and other direction either have two
augmentations or one augmentation
okay um and then they learned the
representations and on these
representations later they um uh did a
classification task so the higher the
number the better so basically from from
this figure we see that um crop and
color have the most effect on the
algorithm
um so basically they they they try to
analyze which which augmentations are
are the most meaningful ones for for
later analysis and then as we can see
crop cutout and
um color are are the most important
ones okay but so the later research
actually
um changed the direction a little bit
and then so it's if you remember we so
here in each badge we had to create
positive Pairs and negative
pairs um but it looks like we we don't
really need the negative pairs we don't
need the negative
samples
um so the next three algorithms that
we'll discuss they they come up with a
different way they pretty much create um
asymmetric Camis Network and avoid this
this collapse issue so the first one is
called B who strap your own latent um um
we have the architecture on on the
slide so we take an image uh we apply
two
augmentations let's say we obtain V and
V Prime and then so f is the the network
that we want to learn f is the one
that's going to give us the
representations so we apply uh let's
let's say the the top and bottom they
have the same exact architecture but
they're going to have different
parameters so let's say the top one th
and the bottom one
C so we apply um f and then we obtain
um the representations and then we apply
the projection so this is exactly
similar to what we had and then um on
top let's say we also have a another
small Network that gives us
prediction so here um this is very
similar to what we had but the
difference would be um that in the
bottom we have this stop gradient which
basically means that when we train this
network the gradients don't pass through
the bottom part okay so we don't really
train the bottom part and we update the
parameters by looking at the top
part um so this is called slow moving
average so we learn the parameters from
the top part and then with some constant
we add to the to what we've already had
in the bottom
part so this is a way to create um
asymmetric Network and avoid the
collapse
what
q q Theta okay it's it's a prediction
Vector so you you obtain this Z
Theta um let me show you here so you
obtain the um z z
Theta from the bottom and the zxc from
the top and zc from the bottom and then
you have have an extra layer here that
gives you a prediction Vector q and then
you try to make sure that these two are
close to each
other okay so here The Innovation is
that we add this top gradient here uh
and we don't train the bottom part and
basically the the network in the bottom
which is called Target so it tries to
mimic the behavior of the network on
top
uh and then the L function is um similar
to the previous one is the um just a
mean squared
error okay and we have the pseudo code
and then here we have the formula for
the exponential moving average so
basically we have we we update the exis
um by its previous value and then we add
some constant times um what we learned
from the top Network
and then we have a similar sud sudo code
we're not going to um read it
again let's let's move forward um so
another network is called steam samam so
they actually analyzed what the previous
method B did
um and they try to see which parts are
are the important
ones again if you see um they have an
image they create two augmentations they
both pass through the
encoder and then from the left one we
have a
predictor
um so as you can see they uh suggested
that the we don't really need the
exponential moving average to update the
um the right part the the target network
but we can just copy what we learn on
the um on the on the left side and they
showed that it's U the exponential
moving average proposed by B um it
doesn't really contribute
much so it's the same exact algorithm
but they remove that exponential moving
average and they showed that it's um the
behavior is
similar
um here or
here yes so the previous C no no no so
the this Theta is what we learn Theta is
what we learn from the uh from the
top right so the gradient passes through
the top so we can learn Theta at each
step after each Epoch we can learn Theta
and
then to is fixed this is a
hyperparameter that you
fix it's a number between zero and one
so you fix a number between zero and one
and then this would be
your maybe we can consider to which
reach minimal variance yeah so they
analyze it in the paper they show the
results for different tows okay so they
they have tow let's say 0.9 0.95 0.99
and they try to pick the best
one um okay so the the simam actually
they um they try to claim that this
exponential moving average um it doesn't
really contribute much
um um and another Network um one of the
most recent ones is called Dino um it
came from meta research couple of years
ago um and it's one of the most popular
ones so it's built on B um they still
use the exponential moving
average uh but instead they they
simplify the network so they first they
make sure that both architectur on left
and right are the same so the left one
is called a student Network the right
one is called a teacher Network um they
have the same exact architecture but
they have different
parameters um and then what their
Innovation is they suggest that um
instead of using the mean squared error
they use cross entropy loss and they
show that it behaves
better okay so again you take you have
an image X you create two augmentations
of it one of them goes through the
student Network the other one passes
through the teacher
Network um then you apply a soft Max
operator you obtain two distributions P1
and
P2 um and then you try to minimize the
cross entropy loss which is written up
there the P1 log P2 log
P1 but this loss is symmetric if we
change order okay that's actually a very
good very good point
so when we look at the suda code we'll
see that once it gives um so it gives
like both variations um so it gives X1
to the student X2 to the teacher and
then the other one as
well
um okay and then they still use the
exponential moving average um we can use
also classical definition of entropy
minus P1 log P P1 minus log P2 log P2 in
this case uh what is the situation I
don't know we have to try um yeah this
this experiment probably costed them a
lot of money they it's yeah they run it
on many gpus for a couple of days so
it's um but yeah it's it's something
something we can
try
um okay and then Le let's see actually
the so so so far we talked about um
self-supervised learning but actually
let's see for example in Dino what um
what this network learns
so we have these uh figures let's say we
have these images and then
um on this image net data set we train
Dino okay without any
labels and then so the backbone is a
Transformer Network so we can have um we
can look at the self attention maps of
the CLS token of
Transformer and we see that without any
labels is being able to distinguish um
figures in in in in images
so this basically means that without any
labels it's able to understand uh what
the objects are um and how objects are
um related to each
other
um okay um and then and actually if if
you look at the first one so for example
half of the U bird is covered but it can
still recover the full bird so it has an
idea what what the objects are
um and then this this is a good um
intuition that this this type of um
self-supervised learning methods can be
used for future um segmentation
tasks um okay and then another totally
another different um direction of work
for self-supervised learning is called
must image
modeling um so here the idea is let's
say we have an image if we erase part of
the image um on to recover it so if
you're successful then we can say that
we learn some
representations okay so we take an image
we split it into U
patches of the same size and then we
throw away some of the patches so if we
can come up with a network that can
successfully um
reconstruct the original image then we
can say that it learned some
representations uh so the most popular
algorithm is called Maya M Auto encoders
um it also came out of uh meta research
lab last
year um so the idea is the following we
take the
image um we cut it into patches and then
we mask mask out some of the patches so
we erase um the content and then
whatever is left we have this large
encoder whatever is left we pass through
this encoder um
and then we have a light decoder a small
decoder that tries to reconstruct the
image um so usually according to their
experiments uh the model works the best
if 75% of the image is thrown away so if
the 75% is must the the model works the
best uh and here we have a couple of
examples um of the performance when we
mask 75% out 85% out and 95% out
out um let's take a few seconds to look
at them
um so the most interesting one is um on
the right bottom so the original
image um is this one and then if we mask
95% of it out this is what remains and
then when we try to recover it this is
what it recovers so if you look at it um
this vegetable in the middle um is not
part of any mask here so the U model
kind of huc hallucinated right it
thought um you'll have tomatoes there so
this pretty much means that it it
understands what the images are what the
objects are it understood that there are
tomatoes here and then it doesn't have
any information what's in between and he
thought it should be
Tomatoes while if you have 85% mask so
you have a couple of Patches from these
uh what is
this um from the green vegetable in the
middle um is being able to recover it
okay so this this kind of um gives us an
intuition that it it learned what the
objects
are um okay and then so how to how to
use this for Downstream tasks so we get
rid of the um we get rid of the
decoder so we get rid of this part and
then if let's say we have an image we
want to learn it representations so we
cut it into patches and we don't have to
mask anything out and then we pass it
through the encoder and it gives us a
vector of representations and we can use
this Vector for Downstream
tasks
um okay so there are a couple of more
recent
approaches um that came out this year
iBot and Doo version two so they tried
to combine these two um approaches
the um the first one that we discussed
um and then this m image modeling but
but they do it in the level of
representations actually I didn't
include them in my talk but um if you're
interested um these are state-of-the-art
um U methods for self-supervised
learning
um yeah I guess this was talk um so here
I included a link I don't know if you
can click on it um so if you click on
this link it will take us to um a web
page called papers with code where we
can see the comparison between um all
these
methods
um but yeah I'll leave it in the
presentation if you're interested um you
can click on it
later thank
[Applause]
question yeah thanks first of all just
wanted to ask you talked about many
methods but what about their needing U
data like to do they need a lot equally
or okay that's actually a great question
um
except this Doo version two all the
other methods are trained on image net
and then this Doo version two um I
actually mentioned it here um it's it's
trained on a larger data set which
contained 142 million images but all the
rest are are are trained on um on image
net data set without
labels so they use the same exact data
set um to train the networks and then um
you can pick your favorite um backbone
let's say it can be CNN or U Transformer
of different sizes and different based
on that you can decide if you need a
larger data set or not so if you take a
larger Transformer with many parameters
you can um you can use a larger data set
um if you have a smaller Transformer you
can use a smaller
one but yeah they're they're trained on
most of them are trained on
imet and I think all of them are
available online so you can download the
weights and then directly find the
representations and the representations
that they learn would
be um what how to say like they would be
similar or very diff I mean since they
perform differently I'm assuming their
presentations are different but if you
have a very specific task domain is very
specific would you then how how would
you choose among these yeah so that
that's actually another great question
that's that's what we worked at Yan and
we try to compare them for some specific
tasks um and then so there are two ways
to evaluate them one you um you compute
the representations and then try to do
nearest neighbor so basically you have
your image you try to take find the
closest image so you can also use this
for retrieval let's say you have 10,000
images and then you find the represent
ation for all of them now you take a new
picture you want to see um what's the
most similar one to this so you compute
this representation and then do nearest
neighbor um
so ideally the closest one should be
should have a similar similar figure
inside but it also depends depends on
the task as far as understood
uh today it was covered self supervised
learning via only image data no
multimodel data
um what do you mean by multimodel I mean
that if we have pairs for example of
images and captions okay so yeah that
that's what I want to hear so this is
called weekly supervised learning so
let's say there's an algorithm called
clip um which is trained on a data set
where you have images and then um
captions um but that's um so some people
call it self-supervised but it's called
it's also called weekly
supervised so it's slightly different
because you have um you have more
information
there although you don't need labels
it's you're given images and captions
and they can be wrong or so but it's not
the same exact um setup what are the
comparisons of weekly supervised methods
and just pure self-supervised methods uh
my guess is that Weekly supervised
methods
somewhat more efficient in metrics on
Downstream task it really depends on a
downstream task um so for example we
um recently we're looking at the
um let's say in let's say you have a
robot and you give it instructions okay
so so here you have image and text so in
these kind of scenarios the weekly
supervised ones are more efficient
because they have seen data set like
that so I think it really depends on a
downstream task if the downstream task
is such that text Data could could have
been useful in that case I think weekly
supervised would have
advantage and there are many uh so clip
is mostly among these
algorithms uh so they kind of came out
together and they're compared a lot so
it's
um we can easily find some comparisons
between
them also they're trained on different
data set clip is trained on um Coco I
think I might do wrong and these ones
are trained on image net
so maybe it depends on the size of data
set if we have lar data set of pairs uh
caption Plus image it will overwhelm no
matter how large the data set of just
pure images exactly exactly okay thank
you thank
you